having several several times a day on
large International sites
Facebook May release a different version
of its software globally
several times a day
and they do that because they're able
to
continuously integrate new modules into
the software test them and deploy them
without having to wait for a formal
release
very few times have ever gotten
notice from Facebook about
a new version of the software other than
notice about a particular new feature
and maybe a tour of that but there's a
no owner's manual for Facebook
you're
intended to learn as you go along test
them and deploy them without them
because it continually changes there's
no way they'll be able to update the
documentation that quickly
the devops is the platform or process
that allows
that to happen
shorter life development life cycles to
a continuous process
a continuous delivery of new features
and
fixes
and there's higher software quality
because of The Continuous testing
process so the market for devops
services
over four billion dollars expected to
Triple by 2025
um and
this is because
as I mentioned all new software
development in the web and mobile
environments Paul is a devops model or
we'll follow the devops model
that means that people who have the
capabilities and skills
to fill roles in devops have lots of
opportunities for different career paths
you can be a devops engineer you can I'm
a devops architect over time you can
specialize in the data engineering
aspect of it you specialize in
reliability aspects you can be a quality
engineer looking at
um
software quality and the processes that
ensure software quality
can
specialize in how devops operates on the
cloud
which lies in how
devops operates in a secure
cyber security environment and of course
you can look at how Ai and machine
learning factoring into devops so all of
these processes
are all these roles are available to you
if you have the right skill set can
evolve into or specialize in any one of
them over time
that you do need up-to-date skills
um you need a complete skill set in
order to be able to
adopt
uh
and thrive in the devops career
you need to understand the devops
methodology
uh
how continuous integration and
continuous delivery deployment work
you need to understand configuration
management and how devops facilitates
that
you need to understand the core
principle of containerization
which is the means by which software can
be updated in a modular fashion
rather than in big all at once releases
you need to understand how devops works
on the cloud
understand Source control and how
versioning and
current generation of software is
protected you need to understand the
process of deploying in an automated
fashion with pipelines other automated
processes you need to understand the
cloud platforms that you'll be using to
deliver
software
devops model
so the first poll question I have for
the audience
is
what has stopped you so far from
picking up training to become a devops
professional devops expert
cool
launch this poll if you're watching on a
streaming service please uh enter ABCD
into your
um
chat box or your comments box will
probably those
but if you're on WebEx you have that
widget in front of you
but
One Two Three or all four of these
answers
keep the
poll open for about 10 seconds more
and here we go
foreign
sponsors
if you're on WebEx you're seeing that
now
almost two-thirds of the audience
says that they don't feel like they
would get practical exposure and
experience that they'd be able to use to
demonstrate job readiness
and then
about a quarter of the audience or two a
third of the audience answered the other
three reasons
so let's
address that
so the way that Caltech Center for
technology management education helps
you become job ready
is through their postgraduate program in
devops
available to Learners worldwide
it is a program of nine months duration
it takes approximately 10 maybe a little
more uh than that in terms of weekly
hours of commitment
because it does have live
virtual classes
eight hours a week
usually two four hour blocks on Saturday
and Sunday
and
it's a comprehensive curriculum it
covers all of the different skills that
spoke of earlier
um designed in partnership with industry
Caltech ctme Works closely with industry
to develop programs that meet the
Staffing and
Personnel needs of Industry so
they designed this program
to be
capable of producing graduates who can
work in devops right away
the program is delivered entirely online
but not only do you have the online
virtual classrooms where you interact
with your instructor and your classmates
can ask your questions directly can get
example shown to you
real-time live but you also have the
ability on the same platform to do your
labs and your projects that develop your
practical experience that give you
something at the end of the program to
show off to potential employers to
demonstrate that you have used these
skills and are proficient in them
and it's flexible to fit your lifestyle
because outside of the live virtual
classes which are at given times on the
weekends you also have your homework to
do but you can do that 24 7 on the
digital platform don't have any
restriction on when or where you can
access that
um want to review some of the
pre-recorded video preparation materials
you can do that on your mobile device
while you're on your commute or
anywhere you are
um and you can do your project work at
any time 24 7. you have the support
platform available to you to help you
get past any questions doubts or
blockers you might
the end of it all
Tech and simply learn will issue you the
postgraduate certificate
certifies that you completed the court
courses of this program that you are
proficient in the skills
Caltech will certify that to anybody who
asks
you can receive up to 25 continuing
education units from Caltech
continuing education units are for
people who are either in
licensed occupations where they have to
prove to the licensing body that they've
taken ongoing education or where they
have employers who require them to
demonstrate ongoing education
a lot of CEUs are the standard method to
demonstrate that taken continuing
education classes
you also get membership in the online
Caltech ctme Circle which allows you to
network with other graduates from
Caltech CTE programs it's a great
Career Development and networking tool
it's available to you for your lifetime
after complete the program
you'll also get an online convocation
where you can invite friends and family
to come watch you be honored as a
graduate of the program
ceremonies
all of those things result from the
program
you also get the advantages of
affiliation with Caltech ctme Caltech is
a California Institute of Technology it
is 130 years old
it's
known worldwide it's the setting for the
sitcom The Big Bang Theory so when the
producers of that show wanted to show
the Pinnacle of technology and
scientific research culture they chose
to set it at Caltech because Caltech is
the home and the alma mater of many
Nobel laureates it's produced
many no laureates from among people who
have studied there and a place where
many double Prize winners have decided
to go to do their research
um it is less of a teaching institution
with respect to
undergraduates it doesn't take on a lot
of undergraduates instead it
focuses on research and doctoral
programs so
consistently ranks in the top five
universities worldwide
and ctme Center for technology and
management education is it specialized
uh executive and
technical education division
that transfers Knowledge from its
research faculty
turns that into
training for direct application in
Industry so having that on your CV on
your resume is the prestigious
accomplishment it will gain recognition
anywhere you go
um the program is also designed in
conjunction with IBM IBM provides
several of the modules within the
program
you take when you take those modules the
elective courses you will receive
certificates issued by IBM for those
you also get access to hackathons and
ask me anything sessions conducted by
IBM employees master classes by IBM
instructors
um yet as I mentioned the certificates
for those courses that you take from the
IBM instructors so that becomes an
additional Advantage instead of
qualifications that you can demonstrate
you have
fairly straightforward set of
Eligibility and prerequisites
do not have to have a programming
background to enter this program
do you however have to have a bachelor's
degree
with a GPA of 2.0 which
50 marks or higher
uh and you do not have to have work
experience although work experience is
always valuable so you understand how
these skills would be applied in the
workplace
but that leads to our next question
I ask
how much experience folks have
ask that question of our audience
that should be fairly straightforward
leave it open about 20 seconds
so are you
brand new to Industry uh recent graduate
or maybe still in
your senior year of University
or do you have more experience in the
workplace
are you a seasoned veteran who's looking
to Pivot into devops from another area
perhaps
let me show answers
or pull results
about 40 percent of our audience are
people with less than two years of
experience
fairly even distribution but about uh
more than a quarter
have more than 10 years of experience so
it's good because this program is
designed to
address both ends of the spectrum there
so moving on
to how this program prepares you sorry
so we're not going to do a live tour of
the learning environment because
ashitosh is not here but I will talk
about the online learning environment
first thing when you log into the
learning management system is you see
your curriculum see all the classes that
are in your program and
they are
displayed in order that you're going to
take them
you're able to access them only in that
sequence you'll start off with your
orientation session which is basically
doing some live video
um
instruction about how the program works
as well as watching some pre-recorded
video to get you oriented to The
Learning Management Systems